thank you very much appreciate it I want
to express our nation's deepest
condolences and most heartfelt
sympathies to the family of George Floyd
a terrible event terrible terrible thing
that happened I've asked that the
Department of Justice expedite the
federal investigation into his death and
do it immediately do it as quickly as
absolutely possible
it's a local situation but we're also
making it into a federal situation and
it's it's a terrible thing we all saw
what we saw and it's very hard to even
conceive of anything other than what we
did see should never happen should never
be allowed to happen a thing like that
but we're determined that justice be
served and I spoke to members of the
family terrific people and we'll be
reporting as time goes by we think that
we also have to make the statement and
it's very important that we have
peaceful protesters and support the
rights for peaceful protesters
we can't allow a situation like happened
in Indianapolis to descend further into
lawless anarchy and chaos and we
understand that very well it's very
important I believe to the family to
everybody that the memory of George
Floyd be a perfect memory let it be a
perfect memory the looters should not be
allowed to drown out the voices of so
many peaceful protesters they hurt so
badly what is happening and it's so bad
for the state and for that great city so
we are working very closely with the
Justice Department we're working with
local law enforcement we're working with
everybody and we're speaking with the
family and hopefully everything can be
fairly
taken care of I understand the hurt I
understand the pain people have really
been through a lot the family of George
is entitled to justice and the people of
Minnesota are entitled to live in safety
law and order will prevail the Americans
will honor the memory of George and the
Floyd family it's very important to us
it's very important to me to see that
everything is taken care of properly
it's a horrible horrible situation and
so we'll be reporting back in due course
and as quickly as possible I'm pleased
to welcome American industry leaders to
the White House as we continue to safely
reopen America we're glad to be joined
by Jeff Pilate of Wyndham Hotel and
Resorts Windham hotels have been really
terrific company over the years Bryan
Goldner of Hasbro Dave Hoffman of Dunkin
Brands Gary Kelly of Southwest Airlines
really good jobs they've done Rodney
MacMullen of Kroger thanks Rodney ask
him you know United Thank You Oscar
United Airlines Brad Smith a Microsoft
that stock has done very well I will say
great job great job
Sonya send olive Gap and thank you very
much also with us a Secretary of
Treasury Steve minuchin and Secretary of
Labor Jeanne Scalia our nation continues
to mourn for the lives claimed by the
virus and grieve for the families who
have lost loved ones we continue to
battle the invisible enemy we're
directing the full resources and support
of the federal government to safeguard
high-risk populations especially in
nursing homes we've been a very powerful
strategy or nursing homes for quite a
while the best strategy for Public
Health
is to aggressively protect the most
vulnerable while allowing younger and
healthier Americans to work safely
nationwide hospitalizations new cases
and deaths are all declining
we are tracking cases and
hospitalizations daily and states are
demonstrating their ability to rapidly
identify and contain new outbreaks our
testing is the best in the world we've
now surpassed 15 million tests which is
much more than any other country by a
factor of many times we've completed
over 15 million and that is I think we
can say that's a record by a lot and
we're going to give you a big report on
testing tomorrow we have new tests
coming out that are above and beyond
anything that anybody would have thought
even possible just a couple of months
ago in many places we've had more tests
available than people seeking them
Florida and others have said that they
have testing and they they don't have
enough people to take the tests so we've
come a long way we started with an empty
cupboard we didn't have a lot that we
inherited and we are I think really
they've stepped up to the plate on
ventilators on tests and on equipment
and gowns and everything else loves if
you look at masks everybody has masks
now to maintain the health and safety of
our society we must also maintain the
health of our economy there's a reason
why our nation's life expectancy is
closely correlated with economic
development a never ending shutdown
would increase not reduce the total loss
of life in the United States while
failing to focus resources on the most
vulnerable we've made a lot of progress
in terms of the invisible enemy a lot of
progress a lot of things have happened
that have taught us a lot nobody has
ever seen anything like this and there
certainly hasn't been anything like this
it's over a hundred years 1917 I want to
thank all of these great companies for
being here and representing their
company and themselves in our country so
well we're going to be having a
discussion with the companies as to
suggestions they have we think we're
gonna have a very strong opening which
is just started really we had the
greatest economy in history of any
country not just ours the greatest in
history we had the best employment
numbers that we've ever had we've had
the best numbers in every way whether
it's the biggest tax cuts the greatest
regulation cuts of any President
nobody's even come close we've rebuilt
our military with the strongest military
we've ever had new equipment coming in
all the time a lot of it already arrived
and very importantly all made in the USA
and so many other things you look at
what we've done for the vets with choice
and accountability the combination they
weren't able to get that done for over
40 years and we got them both approved
right to try got it approved we've done
so much and then we had to turn it all
off in order to be in a position where
we are right now
numbers were estimated to be two million
deaths one-and-a-half million deaths
maybe 1 million but it could have been
over 2 million and maybe substantially
over unfortunately one is too many
should have been stopped he could have
been stopped in China should have been
stopped in China but it didn't stop and
the world got infected and first said
the first same thing but we turned off
the greatest economy ever and we turned
it off very quickly very rapidly we
banned people coming in from China early
very early in fact most people said
don't do it
even a month later they were saying you
shouldn't have done it and we turned out
to be right but we have we have now a
long way to go but we're getting very
good early numbers as everyone knows the
stock market has been doing very well
because people have a lot of confidence
we're doing very well on therapeutics
we're doing very well on vaccines I
think we're gonna have some very good
answers soon and we're set up
logistically with our military
military is set to move and to act so
that when I think I can say when we have
that vaccine I think I can say it with
pretty good surety based on what we're
seeing that rather than taking long
periods of time and bringing it out
slowly we're able to bring it out very
very quickly so we have a general in
charge of logistics that's what he does
and he's supposed to be the best usually
moving soldiers and moving various
things for other reasons but now he's
going to be moving vaccines or
therapeutics depending on what
ultimately ends up but we're doing very
well on vaccines we're doing very very
well on therapeutics and maybe I could
use the word cure as opposed to purely
therapeutic so I want to thank everybody
for being here we have a lot of positive
things to report you see some of the
numbers coming out with some of the
states that have been have been opened
and some of the numbers have been really
really beyond expectation so we're very
happy and I think what we'll do is we'll
go around the room quickly and we'll say
a few things about any ideas you might
have your company how well you've done
with your companies and might as well
give it a little build up you have
plenty of firepower back here so please
thank you thank you mr. president I'm
honored to be here today as representing
Gap Inc and working with all of you to
safely open our stores which is very
important for us right now
have the honor of running America's
largest clothing company Gap Inc had
over 16 billion in revenue last year and
we house four billion dollar brands
between Old Navy Athleta Banana Republic
and our namesake Gap and Old Navy is the
second largest apparel brand in the u.s.
so you know we have serviced American
families for our 51 years and with these
brands represent the best of American
values and we're anxious to get going
and anxious to open up the economy we
have 2,500 stores here in the US and
we've begun the opening process you know
prior to kovat we had over a million
American customers walking through our
doors every day well
and so when we shut in March we lost 70
percent of our sales overnight and we
reacted very quickly we had to make
really big unfortunate decisions to
furlough employees and to retrench we
did have a very strong and powerful
ecommerce business so we're the second
largest um
player for apparel and that's really
kept us going along with our fulfillment
centers we have five big campuses across
the US and so that's been great we have
you know over a hundred thousand
employees that were anxious to really
bring back to work we you know we've
developed these safe shopping protocols
with industry leaders in retail and we
feel really good about them more anxious
to reopen our stores with these
protocols and have been excited about
what's happening so far as we've opened
our employees feel safe our customers
feel safe and they're coming back to
shop with us and so we are committed to
opening at least eight hundred stores
this month and so we're on track for
that in fact we're a little head of that
which feels good and as customers come
in you know they'll have new protocols
social distancing masks and cleaning etc
so it's gonna you know quite trust and
everyone's responding really well
I visited our stores in Virginia last
night and I visit our stores in Texas in
Arizona California over the last couple
of weeks and our customers are thrilled
to be back our employees are thrilled to
be back in fact one of our our store
managers came up to me and burst into
tears thanking thanking me for giving
her her job back you know it's a really
very important thing and as much as the
government government's helped our
employees want to be back so that feels
great
one in four Americans work in retail as
you know so this is now my time to ask
what we need and and during this closure
process half of retail stayed open and
half of retails and shut so we've really
created this lack of level playing field
you know the haves and the have-nots and
as we look forward and as we think about
a possibility of a resurgence or
something we must stay committed to
these safe retailing protocols and
really stay there
and work through any future issues with
that so we can have an equal playing
field so I look forward to working with
you and secretary min has been fantastic
he's done a great job Thank You Sonya
appreciate Steve Thank You mr. president
I really want to thank everybody and
Sonja thank you for all the work you've
done and everyone else I do want to just
particularly thank re and Oscar as part
of the gears fact we've worked with both
of you and the rest of the airline
industry I know many of the businesses
here have been hit very hard but the
travel industry in particular and we
appreciate everything you've done with
us thank you thank you very much
Oscar please that's a heck of a leader
thank you as well thank you and here's
act was great then everybody that was
involved Larry you were terrific as well
in the waning moments you know our story
so I won't belabor it I have two slides
really one just to give you a sense of
the things that we're doing one of the
most converts come and converse that
discussions going our airplanes safe is
flying safe and I think that's a
paramount importance
we've always been one of the safest
industry in the world and so some of the
things that we're doing are on this
chart and it's simply everything even
hydrostatic testing that disinfects
wiping everything down the wire to mass
for everyone we were one of the first to
be able to do that you know touchless
aspects of you know our customers get a
chance to shoot sit choose where they
sit the HEPA filters on our aircraft I
think it's important for the flying
public to understand these HEPA filters
are hospital-grade filters that removed
99.7% of particles in the air the
combination of the filter and the mass
that we're wearing should completely
eliminate to a great degree the aspect
and if we practice all the other things
and so we're working through all of that
but again it feels like we're always
talking into the wind with regards to
that so we took it a step further and if
partnered with different people Clorox
in particular right it's a brand name
that speaks a powerful disinfectant and
if that branding assbutt gives it a
little bit of sense then we want to
threat further and use Mayo Clinic al
Cleveland Clinic apologize to guide us
and direct us here the things that we're
planning on doing is that meaningful
it's like having ambassador birx that
our side to sort of support those things
so those are the things that we're doing
with regards to safety on the next
charge request
how do we how do we restart the economy
if I can get the next chart please the
first ones obvious and I think we've all
been talking it in the business
community it isn't just about Airlines
line people have to go someplace and fly
somewhere right the hotels of the world
you know the hospice and the restaurants
the theme parts all of that has to be
collectively and I think everything we
do as a business and as a government is
to ensure that we take everybody into an
account into account and not forget the
fact that the airlines are only part of
it and so that's an important part and
and then again from a health perspective
I don't know that there's another nation
that has more powerful pull back to
branding in the US and even it comes out
of us is going to be accepted so thank
you for the efforts ambassador was
wonderful in those conversations and
then lastly this is the big ass from our
perspective you know we are global we
need to apply over 60 countries and this
isn't a China question this is the
general aspect of when the world
restarts to fly it's historically every
government every country will have its
own regulatory scheme to start flying
that is called patchwork that is not
harmonization in order to get the
economy going and flowing from a
perspective of the entire planet it's
important that we work with your teams
to get that harmonization and avoid
patchwork so thank you again for ever
thank you I appreciate you've been very
much a factor in what we've done you've
been really helpful we appreciate it
Larry Kudlow please everybody has come
here and work with us I hope everything
continues apace you know I we try to
talk Kevin Hassett and I try to follow
these high-frequency economic indicators
and my little list is growing I'll just
rattle off because things as things open
safely I'd say that because Deb is here
truck loads freight shipping air travel
hotel bookings TSA travelers all
starting to shoot up there really green
shoots you mentioned the stock market
sir which is done very well
Apple mobility gasoline demand
tremendous housing demand applications
for mortgages and so forth are actually
now pre-pandemic
levels again with low interest rates and
we had number today from the income
report the saving rate sir is 33% for
the month of April 33 percent which is
to say we've given them a lot of income
government income is boosted things
liquidity cash and so forth
Stevens great efforts on Capitol Hill
and of course the stores have been
closed they have nowhere to spend so
they're saving at a 33 percent rate
that's almost 10 times the norm so that
my final point as we open and as the
stores open we are gonna see a boom in
spending are they set the store Agron
how people we're starting to see it
doesn't think you're gonna be very
people that'll be very surprised we're
gonna have a great third quarter a great
fourth quarter I think next year is
gonna be one of our better years so
that's really great thank you very much
laughs yes sir
so J Clayton is the head of the SEC
Securities and Exchange Commission and
he's done a fantastic job and I thought
maybe I didn't write them up and you
could say a few words if you'd like
whether they're good or bad
and I really want to thank the many
companies have been very candid with
their disclosure about where they stand
that's what our investors expect I think
you've done a terrific job giving our
investors what they expect thank you
very much thank you
Southwest Airlines what a great company
go ahead well thanks mr. president it's
a pleasure to be here on behalf of all
the Southwest people and my name is Gary
Kelly and again I want to thank you and
I thank Secretary of minuchin the cares
Act was exactly what we needed the speed
and the scope were just absolutely
breathtaking before the markets were
closed and after that the markets opened
up and we've been able to do a
significant amount of financing so thank
you it was it was just the right thing
for our economy
I'll just mirror echo what several have
already said in terms of the business we
got down to about 2% of the normal
traffic volumes and are up well beyond
that thank goodness we're not there but
I'll take 15% as opposed to two so we've
got a long way to go but the trends are
in the right direction I think what is
important is to make sure that our
employees and our customers know that it
is safe and that is our number one
priority to make sure that we have a
healthy and safe environment again I'll
echo a lot of what oscar has already
covered but we published the Southwest
promise in early May and it addresses
cleaning of the airport deep cleaning of
the airplane we require masks of our
customer facing employees as well as our
customers we are not booking the
airplanes full so that the middle seats
are open to allow for physical
distancing and it's a layered approach
the one thing that we would like to see
and I know that the administration is
looking very carefully at this
is to add a health screening at the TSA
checkpoint I think a temperature check
like we had today coming into the White
House would be very sensible along with
a health declaration and we're working
closely with the TSA on that point I
think beyond that I think ongoing tax
burden reduction would be very helpful
in terms of ticket taxes I know we've
got a ticket tax holiday for 2020 as
sales begin to pick up and Airlines
begin to get back on their feet that
could be something worth looking at and
I think for all of us some sensible form
of liability protection which I know is
also a topic would make great sense but
we applaud all that the administration
is doing I think the key indeed is to
get treatments for when people are sick
number one so that they're confident
that they'll quickly get back on their
feet and then number two ultimately
getting a vaccine when that happens I
think that things will absolutely take
off lastly again I wanted to thank thank
you all for the support with a payroll
support program we've never had a
furlough or a layoff or a pay cut in our
history at Southwest and we sure don't
want to have that now so thank you again
and we're going to fight the good fight
here thank you Gary
great job you do for a long time thank
you very much Deborah please
and we've made amazing progress together
with the American people and with you
all as you heard the president described
new hospitalizations are down
month-over-month by 50% mortality the
fatalities that we all grieve are down
significantly week over week we're
excitingly really finding governors and
mayor's being able to respond to the
epidemic in a new way proactive testing
finding new cases contact tracing and
stopping outbreaks we're seeing that
over and over again county by county
Metro by Metro I think we're working
with all of the health care providers
because just as we want to open up a
America safely we want us to make sure
every American has access to health care
we want to see our babies immunized we
want to see them at their well-baby
checkups we want to see pregnant women
cared for in their appointments and we
want to see the hospitals back caring
for people and doing elective surgery
and ensuring people are getting their
cancer screenings so as we open up the
economy we don't know so one of the
store the Americans are not only covin
free but have all their health care
taken care of so you're seeing much
improved numbers much improved numbers
and I think this proactive testing
having enough tests available not only
for diagnosing at the hospitals and
clinic but having an abundance of
testing available to really be able to
do what we talked about is proactive
surveillance going into nursing homes
and in testing a hundred percent of the
residents one-hundred percent of the
workers working in food processing plans
to attest everyone that is there and
really stopping outbreaks before they
start this asymptomatic piece is unique
among diseases and we have that in HIV
we have it in this in this particular
respiratory disease and so you have to
test proactively to find the
asymptomatic no one intends to infect
others they just don't know they're
infected themselves and so working with
States and governors and mayor's to
really set up those testing sites has
really been extraordinary and having a
testing available at that level I think
we're about three hundred fifty four
hundred thousand tests a day we're up to
having tested five percent of every
American
unless it's great I wish the press would
report it but someday they will someday
they're gonna do that
thank you very much never I appreciate
it a lot of progress has been made great
job you're doing thank you please hi mr.
president
I'm Brian Goldner with Hasbro and thank
you for your leadership and for working
closely with the private sector to
reopen the American economy you may know
that Hasbro is nearly 100 year old Rhode
Island based play an entertainment
company with brands like monopoly
transformers play-doh Peppa Pig and nerf
and it's really an honor to be here
today it's also an incredible honor to
see how our brands are resonating with
consumer
more people getting together and
connecting and playing with games and
brands like play-doh as they spend time
together
we were talking as we were coming
together today just how people are
making new connections and we're very
excited about that and then the
reopening of the economy and I also have
to thank you for the partnership that
we've had over time with director Kudlow
and it's great to get the support that
we've seen from secretary minuchin as
well you know from health screenings to
interactive handbooks safe return to the
office safe social distancing staggering
shifts in our warehouses and factory
floors we are safely reopening US
businesses if we could go to the next
slide we've worked closely with
governors in our region the Rhode Island
governor Raimondo and the Massachusetts
governor Baker to design safe reopening
guidelines I'm especially proud of our
Hasbro
safety folks and operations we've set a
standard in our factories and warehouse
operations across the country for
consumer goods manufacturers in fact
we're training other consumer goods
manufacturers to help them open safely
in the u.s. from Massachusetts to Texas
so again I'm very pleased to be here I'm
very proud of our employees they're all
very excited about getting back to work
and we've been working all along and as
our factories closed down during certain
times over the last few months
our teams came together to make face
shields in our factories 50,000 a week
to give to health care workers and we've
made good use of those factories and
we're now happy to see them back up and
running and so thank you again and thank
you for leadership appreciate that thank
you very much I thank you mr. president
great to be here thank you to the team
your leadership team as well and look
I'm here representing our great
franchisees for both brands Dunkin and
and Baskin I don't think a lot of people
realize that we're a hundred percent
franchised and so big brand names
powered by small independent business
owners and we've got a we've got a sane
in the company that we think we've been
getting America running for nearly 70
years and when this crisis hit it was
about keeping the communities running
but it was also about getting America
working again and so we've been guided
by one simple principle if on the next
slide that we've been talking about is
it's been about doing the right thing in
the communities we serve and 90% of our
restaurants have remained open during
the crisis we've rallied around that
mantra of people over profits and and
doing the right thing there and look
we're very proud that we didn't have to
furlough or do layoffs during all of
that and look our great franchisees I'm
really proud of the work that they've
been doing in the communities they serve
they live in these communities they're
proud to be there they serve probably
coffee donuts ice cream two over three
and her hospital they continue to do
that they raise 1.5 million dollars for
food banks including the capital food
bank here in our backyard here in DC as
well and so as somebody said we're
starting to see a lot of hope and
optimism in our business today we're
seeing really good signs of encouraging
green shoots right now we're working
with the franchisees again to get
America working again looking at a
really aggressive hiring campaign over
the summer but I'd say it's three areas
that we focused on that was really a
good North Star for us and the first was
we got in early on a lot of the safety
measures making investments and safety
measures as brand standards across both
brands but for us and brands like Duncan
and Baskin our mission is to give the
consumer as many ways to access your
brand on their terms we know there's a
lot of consumers out there that have
varying levels of comfort in terms of
what's going on right now so whether
it's drive-through curbside pickup
windows delivery you'll hear a lot about
digital today as well giving the
consumer as many options as many choices
to access your brain is important and I
think the last thing I'll repeat what a
few other people said thank you to you
and your administration the federal
government for the PPP program that has
really allowed us to keep our
franchisees standing up allowed them to
continue to serve the communities
and Keep America working and and my
asking all of this would be the second
round the second version of this that's
sailed through the house the flexibility
plan on PPP I'm just hoping that you
know it's it sails through cleanly and
gets to your desk to be signed because
that's another great example of helping
small independent business owners like
our franchisees keep America working
right now so thank you for your
consideration thank you president Trump
and really appreciate the invitation to
talk about reopening businesses in
America my name is Rodney MacMullen I'm
the chairman and CEO of Kroger I
represent over 500,000 associates and
we've hired over a hundred thousand
people over the last two months and you
know our job is to keep our supply chain
operating fresh affordable food and
essentials and we operate twenty eight
hundred stores thirty-five manufacturing
plants forty four distributions
facilities if you look at our associates
we've invested over eight hundred
million dollars in safety procedures and
rewards for our associates over the last
eight nine weeks obviously we all do
everything we can to make sure we keep
our employees safe and on a daily basis
if you look at our customers we have 11
million people a day that come into our
stores so the things that we're doing to
protect our employees we're also doing
the same thing to protect our customers
we use every available way of trying to
remind customers on social distancing
limiting the number of people in the
stores we have an in-store radio network
that every 15 minutes
we remind people of you know social
distancing but everything that we can do
we're trying to remind people to say
safe and do things
we also are supporting our business and
continuing to make sure that we have a
viable strong business over time and
supporting the communities that we
operate in over the last year working
with local food banks we've been able to
over over the last three years over a
billion meals with local food banks and
it's something that you know in the
United States no one should have to go
to bed tonight hungry we have so many
resources as a country and together we
can eliminate food waste and when we
eliminate food waste we can make sure
that one goes to bed hungry obviously is
one of the things that we thought it
would be helpful to pay forward as a
company that's operated throughout the
pandemic we've learned a lot and one of
the things you learned is be agile and
move quickly
and if you think you should do something
you probably should do it with that we
developed a 59 page blueprint that we
made public and we've shared it and I
know the other day I was on The Today
Show and they asked me like four times
why would you do that and one of the
things that was incredibly helpful for
us is other retailers across the world
that were in front of us from the
pandemic standpoint was nice enough to
share their learnings with us and we
thought it was only fair and appropriate
for us to share our learnings with
others we've had over a hundred thousand
site visits on that we've had over
26,000 individuals and companies
download that we get a ton of notes from
small companies in terms of their
appreciation you know if you look at all
the companies in this room we have a lot
of resources but if you think about
somebody with 50 employees or 100
employees or 200 employees the resources
they have is just not the same as us so
sharing that across it's been something
that's been important and it's a real
pleasure to represent all the Kroger
associates and being able to help
America get started again so thank you
mr. president thank you very much and
thank you for all the help to you've
been right from the beginning appreciate
it happy to thank thank you very much
Kevin thank you sir
sir I think that you can sense the
optimism around the room that businesses
really a cross-section of American
businesses collected here are getting
back to work
and I think this cross-section is
extraordinarily representative of what
we're seeing all around America and as
Larry mentioned as you know and as you
require us we watch every little detail
of the gotta be every day and there are
now 27 states 27 states where more than
75% of the businesses are open
that was almost none a few weeks ago and
there are 28 states where 80% of the
workforce is back to work
and so the question then becomes and
last thing I'll say that the people in
this room are saying yes but will we
have demand for our product and what we
learned today and the personal income
report that Larry said is because you
required historic policy action we got
money to people who needed it while they
were laid off because of big
unemployment insurance checks so because
of the $1,200 checks that we mailed
people they have the income now that the
economies are starting again to go out
and demand product and so we're very
very bullish on what's going on with the
restart sir mr. president thank you on
behalf of 7,000 small business owners
Windham hotels and resorts is the
world's largest franchisor a great state
of New Jersey and we have if I could
have the first slide up remarkably
remained open throughout this crisis
much like Dave and and and Duncan our
hotels here in the United States really
never closed
we were we were serving frontline
workers we were serving the National
Guard emergency workers and and a large
part of that had to do I could have the
next slide to the support that and we
really have to the industry has to call
out secretary minutiae and you've been
there for us all along you've listened
to us the PPP Act has been monumental
95% of our franchisees have applied for
either a PPP or an eID alone and we
estimate from the surveys that we're
hearing back that 80% of them have
received one of those and then they view
it as as an absolute lifeline so what
has Dave said is is most important this
is going to be a long recovery even
though we've remained open the most
important thing for our franchisees is
is seeing this this amendment to the
7525 rule which which is in the bill
seeing the expansion of that long loan
term from two years to five years I mean
that's that's critical for our small
business owners and extending as the
secretary and I were talking earlier our
ability to to rehire those employees
that we have had to furlough to be able
to bring them back not have it expire on
June 30 but have that continue till the
end of the year is is critical for us we
also think the idea of a temporary
travel tax to spur leisure travel is
important and we know the administration
is in favor of that and and bringing
back the full deductibility of necessary
business expenses to spur business
travel would be very very helpful to
opening opening our country up again
because as as Oscar said as Gary said
just as planes are safe hotels are safe
they're safe because we've been safe
throughout this crisis with with again
90% of our hotels operating it at low
occupancy demand is coming back but we
need we need those consumers to feel
safe and we just thank you for
everything that you and secretary and
Congress is doing on on this industry's
behalf because it's going to be a tough
road back what's going away vaccines and
I think we're going to have therapeutics
and maybe even beyond that maybe a cure
and it won't be in the longest and so I
really think that's gonna be helpful and
regardless it's going away but that
would certainly speed up the process so
we appreciate it Jeff thank you very
much Jeanne Thank You mr. president
thank you for bringing together so many
great companies different companies
different sectors of the economy that
some of them been affected really very
different ways during the pandemic some
able to stay open some really having
great difficulty doing it but one thing
we've heard today and we had
conversations earlier before the meeting
got underway I think all of them are
very very focus
just on safety safety their customers
safety of their employees I don't think
there's been a time when American
businesses have been as focused on
safety as as they are right now and
that's a great thing for bringing
customers back bringing workers back
it's it's been a focus of ours at the
Labor Department actually since January
we've tried to help American workers
through this crisis in so many different
ways but as early as January we were
helping providing guidance guidelines to
businesses we've now put out guidelines
to 16 different specific industries on
how they can reopen safely we'll
continue to do that so that companies
understand what's expected of them can
have confidence in what they need to do
and same for workers and and we're
mindful that not every company is gonna
focus the right way on these things so
we'll continue to respond to employee
concerns complaints as they come in as
Larry and Kevin said mr. president we've
turned a corner we put out unemployment
numbers yesterday showing that for the
first time since February the number of
people on unemployment dropped and and
that's that's great that the number of
filing is still much higher than good
sign that's a good sign is it we turned
the corner mr. president and we'll get
back there to that extraordinary economy
that you built
so recently and and and we're gonna do
it safely thank you James very much
Microsoft that's a good job they've done
Deborah right thank you very much
well well Thank You mr. president and I
just think this is a fascinating
conversation because it really shows how
each industry is unique and as an
economy we need to meet the needs of
every industry and put the economy
together not surprisingly when you're in
a business and you're in a sector that
creates the tools that people can use to
work from home it's not difficult to
have your own employees work from home
and that's what we've been doing but I
think our mission in this first phase
has really been much broader than that
it's been twofold one is to provide the
data resources and the technology to
support the public health needs of the
country from public health agencies to
hospitals to the researchers as you
mentioned who are on the quest for a
vaccine and therapeutics and the like
and I think more broadly it has been
to work with Franklin many of his
companies around this table to sustain
the economy these past few months so
that employees could work from home so
students could study from home so that
the government could operate from home
when that was needed now it's all about
Phase two and I think you put it well
it's all about both protecting public
health and reopening the economy and
here we see in some ways something that
may look more like a dial than a switch
as we go through this series of phases
we think we're all likely continue to
see different industries with different
needs we do see technology playing some
new and important roles and on this
slide which you have to stand within
three feet up to read you'll see the
nine different areas where we see
different public health needs but
there's three I want to call out because
I think they're especially important for
the private sector the first is the
ability to use technology to work with
people to detect the disease
I thought the reference to a health
declaration was a really good one it
makes sense at the airport many
employers are gonna want that on some
kind of self attestation basis for their
employees it doesn't make sense to do it
on a piece of paper right we were
developing an app for our employees we
realize well everybody's employees need
this so we're now partnering with United
Health Group so it can be made available
to everybody the second layer that I
think is really important for the
private sector is that is the tracing
capability and we're seeing both
companies like Microsoft and others work
to create tracing technology that can be
used by individuals that can be deployed
by employers or by health public health
agencies and then the last is
notification exposure notification that
can be done by individuals with public
health officers I think the key to all
of this is captured of the next slide we
want people to be comfortable using this
technology we need to protect people's
privacy so that they know that they're
not putting their personal information
at risk when they use technology in this
new way
so we're very committed to doing that in
closing I would say when you step back
from this this is also at the right time
to close the broadband gap which you're
addressing through stimulus efforts and
I think there are more it's the right
time to invest in more skilling because
we are going to see more jobs demand
more digital skills than we did six
months ago and it's the right time to
maintain the focus as you have said on
testing you noted the progress we've
noticed the progress we appreciate the
progress but I think even more than the
progress is frankly the high ambition
level the administration has set to
sustain that progress because I think by
fall if we want students to return to
college campuses if we want more
employees to feel safe in the workplace
we're gonna see more private sector
institutions wanting the ability to test
people even when they're asymptomatic
and so that progress I think will be
another one of the fundamental
ingredients that we'll need so thank you
well thank you very much and your first
picture was so beautiful the picture of
the White House I don't think I've ever
seen one you must have something very
special over at Microsoft wasn't that
beautiful
we appreciate it thank you very much
thank you very much you have any
questions please any for the great
executives it's obviously been a long
day for a lot of Americans but I'd like
to give you an opportunity to address
some of your tweets from this morning
you tweeted when the looting starts the
shooting starts how would you know that
phrase and not know it's racially
charged history well I've heard that
phrase for a long time I don't know
where it came from where it originated I
view that phrases well I don't know I've
also heard from many other places but
I've heard it for a long time as most
people happen frankly it means when
there's looting people get shot and they
die and if you look at what happened
last night and the night before you see
that it's very common and that's the way
that was meant and that's the way I
think it was supposed to be meant but I
don't know where it came from I don't
know where it originated I wouldn't know
a thing like that but I will say it's
very accurate in the sense that when
you do have looting like you had last
night people often get shot and they die
and that's not good and we don't want
that to happen yeah please
Thank You mr. president in the past
you've criticized NFL players for their
protest against police brutality given
what we've seen with George Floyd and
what we saw with the delays in the case
of a Marberry does that change your
views around those in a failed protest
and also given if you had a message for
those in the streets of Minneapolis do
you have a statement to make about the
police that are involved in such police
brutality and say yeah I didn't like
what I saw at all I thought it was a
terrible thing that terrible picture I
think that it's it said in so many ways
from the standpoint of the family when
you look at George Floyd and his family
and you see what that's done to them
just just a terrible thing that he was
in tremendous pain obviously and
couldn't breathe it was very obvious to
anybody that watched it it was a very
very sad thing for me to see that we
also know that most policemen you see
the great job they do they do a
fantastic job but this was a terrible
insult to police and to policemen and I
know the Justice Department well as you
know it's a local local case but I know
the Justice Department is also looking
at it very strongly does that change
your views around the NFL protest on
this issue they were peaceful protesters
they're changing I think you really had
the in memory of George Floyd I think it
should be peaceful it's it's terrible he
spoke with his family today terrific
people I think it's so bad for the
memory when you see a thing like that
going on and hopefully that won't happen
tonight and as you know the National
Guard has arrived
and they're there but hopefully
everything will be very different
tonight less that was very sad on many
different levels yeah please
we see tensions with China or the virus
now over Hong Kong or we wouldn't see
the start of a cold war between the
United States and China well we're
certainly not happy with what happened
with respect to China they have a virus
that started and when it got out of
control perhaps I assume that's what
happened it got out of control
whichever way and they stopped it from
going to China but they didn't stop it
from going to the rest of the world so
nobody likes that that was not good they
did not do a good job so I don't know if
it was incompetence or it was done for
some other reason but I know that I
didn't see anything in Beijing and I
didn't see anything in other Chinese
cities but I did see them in New York in
London in Paris we saw them in Spain and
we saw them in Italy we saw that the
enemy the invisible enemy come out and
all over the world 186 countries and
probably more than that now and they
stopped it in China but they didn't stop
it going to Europe and the United States
and the rest of the world so what's that
all about and we have to do a very
strong study and figure that out
are you going to eliminate the special
status for Hong Kong I know you
announced the measures oh we're talking
about doing a lot of things and we're
not we're very very saddened by what
happened to our relationship with China
they should have never allowed this to
happen they could have stopped it at the
source we asked them to come in and help
them and they didn't want help from
anybody even the World Health
Organization they wanted to go in and
they were delayed but we asked to go in
very specifically and they didn't want
any help they didn't need any help and
then it got out of control in some form
but it didn't seem to get out of control
when it came to going to other parts of
China because it didn't go very far but
it did come to the United States it did
come to Europe and went all over the
world
with the Floyd family after the
rose-garden event what was the the
things we were trying to impress upon
them and did they have a message for you
well I just expressed my sorrow that was
a horrible thing to witness and I've
seen bad things I've seen many bad
things and that was just a just a
horrible thing to witness and to watch
and it would certainly look like there
was no excuse for it they were grieving
very much their brother and they were
grieving and I could see very much that
they loved their brother president the
United States in Brazil right now have
more cases than of kovaydin 19 than any
other college can you understand me
I want Brazil you say yes my question is
there are many comparisons between the
way you and the Brazilian President
handled the pandemic do you think is a
fair comparison and how long do you
think the travel ban will be in place
well the Brazilian president is a friend
of mine and he's working very hard and
they do have a big big outbreak and I
can tell you he's a very good man and he
loves his country incredibly well
they've had a hard time there's no
question about it they went a different
route than we did here to shut down they
decided to do it a different way they're
having a very hard time he is against
social distancing at the moment he is
against social distancing in lockdown at
the moments where the numbers in Brazil
were skyrocketing why do you think about
that well he went a different way
Brazil went a different way and
certainly they're having a hard time I
don't want to be critical of anybody
because I have great respect for him and
he's doing a very good job with the
country then he got hit he got hit like
everybody else they went about it
differently than us I closed down from
China I closed down from Europe and we
did a lot of close downs we had to close
down from Brazil you're asking about
Brazil we close down as you know the
other night from Brazil but he's
it's tough times they're having in
Brazil it's a great country great place
great people but they're having a very
tough time how long do you think the
band will be in place for Brazil and I
also think of Russia yeah I'd like to
take the ban off as soon as we can as
soon as we can yes do you believe that
there's a problem with police brutality
in America and if you do what what would
you do about it well I think that police
brutality certainly is something that
we've been hearing about reading about
studying I have for many years and we
all have to say and I think most people
would admit that most of the police men
and women that I've seen have been
outstanding when you have something like
this happen you really you look at it
and you just say how does a thing like
that happen because it just seems so bad
to watch but our police have been very
outstanding our crime rates are way down
right now in this country and way down
the police have done a great job
something like this happens and you
really say that so is that so bad in so
many different ways and and so
unfortunate mr. president it certainly
seems like you're sympathetic to some of
the frustration expressed by the
protesters last night when I asked you
first off do you think there were good
people out protesting in Minneapolis
last night today where they say were
there good people among the protesters
and then also more broadly what is your
message to black Americans and others
who just are really frustrated and
saddened to see another video of a black
man being killed in police custody well
certainly there were a lot of different
people and there were good people too
and they were protesting and they were
protesting for the right reason they
were protesting in honor of a man George
Floyd where something happened that
should have happened in my opinion from
what I've seen certainly something
happened that shouldn't have happened
and yeah you had a lot of people out
there that were protesting out of sorrow
and then you had people that got out of
control some people and they did a very
I think they did a great disservice to
their state and to their city and to to
really our country what they did last
night
and we brought in the National Guard
today and they're there and that won't
happen again it can't happen again we
can never let that happen again that was
run by the mayor of the city and it got
in all fairness to him he was in a tough
position but I don't think they were
very well prepared but we brought in the
National Guard they'll be very prepared
tonight thank you all very much thank
you please thank you